with the blue function complete the
interpreter jumps back out to where that
function was called and the current
context moves out as well furthermore
this was all part of the first call to
new saga which is now completed running
the red new saga function a second time
would result in drafting a new separate
red context which itself contained two
new blue contexts almost all the exact
same steps would occur and although they
would each happen one at a time let's
picture them all popping up at once so
that we can see them without having to
run the entire simulation one line at a
time notice that the values found in
these new contexts will be entirely
different and it's actually stored in an
entirely new saga variable although the
second saga function was created by the
same lines of code that created the
first one the two would fail a triple
equals test that compared them creating
two equivalent looking functions but
that have different identities is
exactly like what happens when you see
an array literal appearing within a
function definition calling that
function twice creates two different
array objects and so this line would log
the value false because the two array
objects do not pass a triple equals
comparison the same would be true of
these two function objects because they
were created by the same lines of code
in two different invitations of the new
saga function what two strings do you
think would be logged as a result of
this second call to the new saga
function